es muy complicado identificar qué pero
castillo pueda llegar a sus cinco años
de mandato incluso si esto lo señalen la
constitución a partir del 2016
lamentablemente la vacancia presidencial
se ha tomado se ha tornado en un tema
numérico en lugar del respeto a la cerca
de lo que se señala en la constitución
es decir un término tan ambiguo como una
vacancia por incapacidad moral
permanente hace de que cualquier
gobierno que no cuente con mayoría en el
congreso pues pueda ser removida y este
es el caso de pedro castillo quien
además ha tenido una serie de
comportamientos erráticos y que ha
perdido no solamente popularidad desde
la ciudadanía sino también perdido apoyo
político desde el parlamento si
precisamente usted ha hablado del
congreso peruano que parece ser más
poderoso que el mismo ejecutivo y ha
removido del cargo a numerosos
mandatarios existe la posibilidad de
cambiar esto y evitar que la figura de
la moción de censura sea usada con fines
políticos
el nombre es moción de vacancia la
censura normalmente se le hace a los
ministros pero en este caso
lamentablemente el ejecutivo y el
legislativo está liderado por una elite
política que no ve a largo plazo sino en
todo lo contrario a corto plazo y
pareciese cualquier cualquiera de ellos
tanto el ejecutivo como el legislativo
puede
decidir bajar un presidente o en todo
caso cerrar el parlamento en tokio en
ese sentido es muy importante que los
políticos peruanos sean responsables
sobre el futuro y la estabilidad
democrática del perú sin embargo esto no
se va a dar de lana y probablemente
vamos a seguir viviendo inestabilidad
excepto que pues los políticos sean
responsables y yendo en concreto a esta
moción de vacancia como usted ha dicho
se sustenta sobre más de 20 puntos nos
puede contar que alega la oposición
ahora para iniciar este proceso
la cuestión es que el gobierno de pedro
castillo tenía una serie de
comportamientos que generan
algún tipo de suspicacias en temas de
corrupción o en temas de favoritismos o
malas decisiones políticas sin embargo
en términos reales e institucionales no
necesariamente esto determinaría una
vacancia me parece que en este caso
sería fundamental que se desarrolle con
mayor fortaleza
porque eso serían las razones
específicas por las cuales marcaron un
presidente